Jesse: All right. Thanks, everyone, for joining
us for another live in San
Francisco Authors@Google talk. Today we have
Anil Ananthaswamy talking about
"The Edge of Physics." He is a consultant
-- or was a consulting editor --
still is -- for "New Science Magazine" in
London, umm, he was a computer
scientist I believe for --
Anil: Software Engineer.
Jesse: Software Engineer for about ten years,
uh, he's contributed to "National
Geographic News". Very, very well educated
in the field but also extremely good
at relating physics to -- to the rest of us
basically. Umm, prior to moving to
London, Anil lived in Berkeley. So Anil, welcome
back to San Francisco.
>> [Applause]
Anil: Hi, everyone. Can you hear me clearly?
Umm, it's a double pleasure for
me to be here in, uh, the Bay Area. As Jesse
said, I used to live here and work
as a software engineer so, uh, about ten years
ago I moved onto write about
science and, uh, so it's kinda nice to come
back and start speaking about this
to people that I used to work with. Umm, so
just to, uh, tell you a little bit
about this presentation, I -- I won't be reading
from the book. I wanted to
show you some slides of the various trips
I've made to write the book and these
trips were to some pretty remote parts of
the earth, from the Atacama Desert in
Chile, to Lake Baikal in Siberia in the winter,
umm, to Antarctica and to the
South Pole. Umm, before I start showing you
the slides, I just wanted to sort
of tell you how I came upon, uh, the idea
for the book. For the longest time I
wanted to just travel to mountain tops and
write about telescopes and, uh, uh,
it was a very thin idea and I don't think
any publisher would have really liked
it and it sort of languished like that for
a long time. And then about 2004,
umm, I became physics news editor for "New
Scientist" in London and as part of
that I moved to -- I came to Berkeley and
Stanford to meet scientists just to
get a idea of what's happening in physics
so that I could do my job better.
And -- and it was one of these discussions
with a cosmologist in Berkeley where
I -- at the end of the discussion with him
I mentioned to him that I would like
to write about telescopes on mountain tops
and he planted the seed in my head
saying that, oh, you don't have to stop at
mountain tops. You can literally go
to the extremes, uh, of this planet where
there are other experiments that are
also, uh, important for physics and cosmology
if not more important and that
sort of set the whole thing in motion. And
I realized I could tell the story of
what's happening in physics and cosmology
but through the eyes of a traveler
who's going around to these various places
and talking about experiments rather
than the theory. I mean, the theory is very
integral to the book. It -- it
makes its presence felt all over the book
but the heart of the book is really
about the experiments that are, uh, going
to be necessary, uh, to start sort of
answering some of the very big questions in
physics. And I'll briefly mention
some of the big questions in physic as we
go along. So let me just move on
then. Uh, the first chapter -- the slides
are -- that I'm presenting now,
they're organized in a narrative that is,
uh, as it is in the book. These
are -- these were -- this is not the sequence
in which I made the actual travels
but, uh, I think they work better if I stick
to the order that I used in the
book. So I started off in, uh, California
at the Mount Wilson Observatory near
Pasadena and, uh, this is where in the 19
-- early 1900s Edwin Hubble discovered
that the universe was expanding. So if you
think back to the early 1900s, our
conception of the universe was just the Milky
Way. We had really no idea of
whether there were any galaxies and if there
were -- if there was
anything else outside the Milky Way. And Hubble
was the first to really show
conclusively that not only were there are
galaxies outside the Milky Way but
also that they were moving away from us at
-- in a very specific fashion. So,
uh, this was, for me, uh, a pilgrimage to
a very old and venerable telescope
just to see what it's like. So this is the
view of the -- you see the dome of
the hundred-inch telescope. This is atop Mount
Wilson and you can see this from
Pasadena on a clear day. Uh, I should confess
this is not my picture because
the day I landed up in, uh, Pasadena, it was
completely cloudy and raining and I
couldn't see any of this from the outside.
Umm, this is inside the dome. Uh,
this is the hundred-inch telescope that was
actually used by Hubble to, uh,
figure out the expansion of the universe.
What Hubble managed to do was that he
figured out a relationship between, uh, the
galaxies that are moving away from
us and the distance, uh, that they lie from
us and if you work backwards in time
using -- using this relationship, this mathematical
relationship that he came up
with between velocity and distance it became
very obvious that there must have
been a time in the past where all these galaxies
were at one point, they were
sort of speeding away from each other and,
uh, and that was literally the thing
that laid the foundation for the Big Bang
Theory. Apart from Einstein's
Equations of General Relativity, uh, this
is where observational cosmology
began. Umm, I -- I just wanted to show you
this particular galaxy. It's called
the Sombrero Galaxy. Umm, it's a striking
picture and it is nothing like what
people like Hubble would have seen. This is
actually taken with a 4-meter glass
telescope in Chile. The reason I mention -- bring
this up is because even
before Hubble did his work, there was an astronomer
called, uh, Vesto Melvin
Slipher who, in the early 1900s in a -- using
a telescope in Arizona, uh, was
beginning to understand that these galaxies
were moving away from us. Umm, at
the time, these were not even called galaxies.
We didn't know what they were.
They just looked like clouds in the sky -- they
were called nebulae -- and he
figured out that these nebulae were actually
receding and this particular one
was receding at about 1100-kilometers per
second and, uh, and when, umm, Slipher
mentioned this at a meeting of astronomers
in 1914, uh, everyone stood up and
clapped because they realized that they were
hearing something very momentous
but it wasn't clear what. What Slipher hadn't
been able to do was figure out
the distance to these galaxies. He just knew
that they were moving away from us
and then Hubble came along and did much, much
-- uh, many, many more
observations and with a much bigger telescope
at his disposal, he was the one
that figured out that these were moving away
from us, uh, and they were outside
the Milky Way. And so -- and this is just
to give credit to Slipher who often
goes unmentioned when we talk of discovery
of the expansion of the universe.
Umm, this, uh, is -- this was and still is
the living quarters of the
astronomers. Umm, it's called the monastery.
George Hale, who founded the
observatory in the early 1900s, was fascinated
by monks and felt that his
astronomers should live like monks, uh, and,
uh, avoid any distractions. So he
had a very sexist rule. He basically banned
women astronomers from coming and
working there because he thought that they
would be a distraction to the men.
Umm, and, uh, thankfully by 1950s that rule
was abolished and it's -- uh, some
very, uh, well-known women astronomers have
worked there since. Umm, the man
that you see was my guide. He's a 90-year-old
man who actually was uh, uh, was the
son of a staff astronomer at Mount Wilson
and he, umm, essentially hobnobed with
Hubble and so he was my living link to Hubble
which was quite -- quite a lovely
thing. Umm, he's 90 and he still comes up
almost every day as a volunteer guide
to show people around. Umm, and so let me
just back up here a bit. Uh, so what
happened was by the 1930s, uh, Los Angeles
was getting really big and, uh, light
pollution was beginning to be a factor and
this was -- this observatory is actually not
very far from, uh, the whole region. So George
Hale who built this one, uh,
figured that he needed to build a bigger telescope
somewhere further inland and
he moved to a place called Mount Palomar,
uh, which is a much higher mountain
and in a much darker region with far less
li -- light pollution at that time --
it's already polluted now. But one of the
things that happened in mount Palomar
in the 1930s was there was an astronomer -- a
Bulgarian-born astronomer called
Fritz Zuicki who started studying a cluster
of galaxies in the Coma Cluster and
he was looking at the speed at which these
galaxies were moving around in the
cluster and those speeds are indicative of
how much mass there is in the
cluster. So the speeds can tell you, uh, the
gravity of the cluster that's
holding these galaxies together and he figured
out that, uh, just by looking at
these galaxies that there must be much more
matter in -- in the galaxy cluster
than was visible. So that was the beginnings
of our understanding that in the
universe there is something else apart from
normal matter. Normal matter being
the matter that we are used to made of electrons,
protons, neutrons, and the
like, uh, and he figured that there was some
other kind of matter, something
else that was providing the enormous gravity
for these clusters that was holding
up -- holding these galaxies together. This
was 1930s, late 1930s and he, uh, -- no one
really paid attention to it because it was
a fairly outrageous
claim for its time but then, umm, then by
the 1960s people started actually
making observations of nearby galaxies and
started realizing that indeed what
Zuicki had come up with was actually true
-- and that, uh, unseen, uh, aspect of
the universe we now call "dark matter."
And my next trip was to an underground
mine in northern Minnesota to see an experiment
that is actually trying to detect
dark matter. The reason why it's called "The
Experiment That Detects Nothing"
is, uh, not to demean the experiment but it's
basically -- the idea of the
experiment is that it should be built in a
way where all the noise that is
present on earth, from cosmic rays, from ambient
radioactivity, all sorts of
things -- should be excluded from the experiment.
In the sense that you should be able to filter
out everything that could possibly create
a false signal so that it detects
nothing from the environment and at that point
if you do see a signal, it will
most likely be a dark matter particle and
I'll talk a little bit more about
that. So the reason why it's inside a mine
is also because you have to protect
yourself from all the sort of environmental
noise on the surface. So, umm, and
before I show you slides of the mine itself,
uh, this -- in the 1960s, this is
the Andromeda Galaxy. This was, uh, a galaxy
that was studied by an astronomer
called Vera Rubin. She's in her 80s now, umm,
and, uh, I went to see her
personally and she was quite amazing. She
talked about this galaxy as if she
was observing it just yesterday and, uh, one
of the things she figured out was
if you look at the -- if you look at the galaxy
you'll see that there are a
whole host of stars in the very center can
as you go further and further away it
gets sort of thinner but there are stars all
the way to the very edge and if you
just apply simple sort of Kepler's laws and
Newton's laws to -- to the motion of
the stars in this galaxy, uh, what should
happen is that the -- the stars at the
very center should be moving really fast and
as you move away, further to the
periphery of the galaxy, the stars should
start slowing down. It's just like in
our solar system you have Mercury moving very
rapidly around the sun and as
you move further away all the way to Pluto,
Pluto actually moves at a very
leisurely pace. That's just simple Newtonian
physics, uh, when she observed the
velocities of these stars, uh, all the way
to the very edge -- in fact she
went -- they had a good enough instrument
where they can go beyond the visible
edge of the galaxy and just looked at ionized
hydrogen so the hydrogen was part
of the galaxy and they found that everything
was moving at almost the same
speed, that there was no falloff in the speed
of these stars as you moved away
from the center. Something was wrong and again
the only explanation is that
there is some matter in this galaxy -- and
indeed in all galaxies -- that
outweighs the matter that you see almost ten
to one and that's providing the
gravity that is holding these stars together.
If that wasn't there, the stars
at the very edge would just fly off and they
wouldn't be there. The galaxy
couldn't be held together. So this was the
first serious piece of evidence,
observational evidence that -- that the universe
is made of a different kind of
matter, or at least has a predominant component
that is dark matter. And, uh,
so -- so -- this was a trip to the mine. It's
about four hours' drive from
Minneapolis and as luck would have it I chose,
uh -- I actually flew from San
Francisco to Minneapolis and, uh, it was very
sunny in Minneapolis and I
landed -- it was very sunny in San Francisco.
I landed in Minneapolis it turned
out there was a blizzard on the way so I literally
had to race north, leaving
the blizzard behind which all added to the
drama, helped in writing the book.
Umm, so this is the head frame of the mine.
This mine is an abandoned iron
mine. It was built in the nine -- 1880s and
it lasted until the 1960s and it
was a very, very good iron ore mine for the
U.S. It was one of America's
premier iron ore mines and, uh, once it was
abandoned, uh, when it became too
expensive to mine it, it was closed but then
physicists discovered it about two
decades ago and they started building an underground
laboratory essentially for
experiments which needed to be shielded by
cosmic rays on the surface of the
earth you go underground. So in this case
you go about a half a mile
underground, uh, using just this shaft. That's
all there is. It's a -- a cage
that's been operating since when the mine
was functioning. And it takes three
minutes in complete darkness and it's a rattling
ride. I'm -- I have to
confess, I was more than a little scared.
Uh, and, uh, and you come down to the
bottom, the cage opens, and this is the sign
that you see: 2,300 feet below the
surface. And as you look to your left, as
soon as you get out of the of the
cage is this thing called a "drift tunnel."
The drift tunnel was the tunnel
that was dug in order to get the ore from
sort of where the seams were and we
took a ride. This is a 3-quarter mile-long
tunnel and you go -- go in all the
way and now there are lights but at that time
they would have been working
without all these, uh, electric lights. And
you can see these gigantic caverns
that have been left behind by the miners.
The caverns are -- they can have
ceilings up to a hundred feet high, even more
and, uh, so this is inside one of
the caverns. Our guide, umm, lit up this candle
-- shut off all the lights and
lit up this candle just to show the kind of
light that the people -- the miners
had to work with. This was it. This was the
light with which they worked with
decades on end. And then I told you as you
turn left you go into the drift and
into the caverns. If you turn right, you see
this. And, uh, it's an
extraordinary laboratory. It's called the
Sudan Underground Laboratory and
there are two massive caverns that are in
there. And you have to imagine, there
are tens of thousands of tons of material
there. Each of those -- every piece
has to be brought down in literally cage-size
pieces, piece by piece. So even
the design of the experiment has to be done
so that you can actually dismantle it, put
it
in that cage, bring it down and -- and assemble
it underground. And that
particular experiment that you see at the
far end is a neutrino detector, which
is not what I went to see there, but, uh,
it's -- it's quite an experience being
down there. Umm, so this is, uh, uh, the two,
uh, people who are showing me
around, uh, one of the lab technicians and
a physicist. We're about to step
into the so-called radio frequency room. That's
a room that has been
electromagnetically isolated from everything
else and that's where the dark
matter detector is placed and you can see
that we are dressing up as if we're
going into a clean room. In fact, it's worse
than going into a clean room.
Even ambient radioactivity, your bodies are
radioactive enough that the detector
will pick it up. And so, uh, the detector
itself is shielded in, umm, uh, you
know, inches thick of lead and lead itself
has a radioactive isotope, lead 210,
which decays, so in order to protect that,
uh, sort of decaying lead from the
detector they have another layer of lead which
was salvaged from ships that had
sunk off the coast of Europe in -- about 200
years ago. So most of that lead,
that is old lead, the radioactive isotopes
have decayed and they use that to
shield the experiment from the new lead and
so on and so forth. It's, uh, it's
a staggering thing. And my tape recorder,
my camera, anything that we were -- I
was taking had to be wiped clean with alcohol
because even fingerprints -- when
you sweat, there's radioactive elements in
your sweat and if it shows up your
fingerprint, the detector will pick it up.
So you can imagine how sensitive
this detector is. So that's essentially what
they're building, something that
detects nothing. The detectors are, umm, silicones
of -- I mean, crystals of
germanium and, uh, silicon, they're hockey
puck-sized crystals that are put
inside this copper tube. This copper tube
is ultra pure. Uh, it's, uh, oh.
Lots of stories about how everything has to
be pure enough that no amount of --
they are essentially trying to negate any
radioactivity in the vicinity -- this
thing is then cooled down to near absolute
zero and then shielded with all the
layers of lead and stuff to prevent, uh, environmental
noise. And the idea here
is that dark matter is something that is supposedly
filling up our galaxy.
This, like I said, ten -- ten times more matter
in the galaxy that is made of
dark matter than normal matter. So what that
mean is, earth, as it's moving
around in the solar system and the solar system
is moving through the periphery
of the galaxy we are plowing through a sea
of these dark matter particles and
the hope is that -- and by definition, dark
matter does not interact with normal
matter which is why we don't see it. We can
only discern its gravitational
influence. Umm, but there is a way in which
you can detective if indeed it's
made of dark matter particles and that is
if a particle were to hit the nucleus
of say a germanium crystal, or a germanium
atom or a silicon atom. Now, uh,
so these detectors are cooled down to absolute
zero and they're hoping that when
one of these particles hit their germanium
crystal or, uh, silicon crystal, it's
going to raise the temperature of that crystal
by a few micro Kelvin or it's
going to induce vibrations in the la -- crystal
lattice and you can imagine how
sensitive that experiment has to be. So it's
cooled down to near absolute zero,
shielded by all these things, and that's what
they're doing. They're watching
for an impact from a dark matter particle.
It's been going on for years and
they haven't seen any yet. Umm, and it's -- but
the experiments are getting
bigger and more sensitive. So there's hope
that maybe this year or the next
year something might pop out. I don't know
if you know, but in December there
was a bit of a fuss about this particular
experiment having detected two events.
About -- after they had done all their exclusions
of environmental noise and all
the statistical cuts that they need to do,
they were left with two events that
they couldn't explain and they think it was
dark matter but it's not
statistically significant enough. There's
a one in four chance that it is still
noise and for particle physics that's an absolute
no-no. So no one claimed
discovery but at the same time there was considerable
excitement because it's
the closest they've come to actually seeing
anything. Now, this experiment is
trying to do what is called "direct detection"
of dark matter. There are other
ways in which you can detect dark matter and
the other obvious way is indirect
detection. So if our galaxy is filled with
these dark matter particles, they
will, umm, assemble in regions of high gravity.
So at the center of the Milky Way
there is a super massive black hole and, uh,
the gravity obviously is really
high out there and dark matter particles tend
to accumulate there and when they
are accumulated in very great numbers they
will collide with each other and the
properties of the particles, theoretically,
are supposed to be such that if they
collide they will annihilate and create other
particles that we can observe.
And, uh, so there are experiments that are
looking for these -- these secondary
particles that should be coming out of dark
matter interactions. And I went to
see another experiment -- this was in Siberia.
They have something called a
Lake Baikal neutrino telescope. Uh, neutrinos
are subatomic particles that are
very much like dark matters in the sense that
they absolutely do not interact with
normal matter in the way that you would think.
Uh, they -- if you stacked up a
light year of lead, one light year, umm, thick
stack of lead and you fired a
low-energy neutrino at it it'll probably go
right through it. Uh, so it's --
it -- you know, the interactions are so, so
little. But neutrinos are real
particles. We know that they exist, we've
collected them in copious numbers so
they're not sort of hypothetical particles
like dark matter particles. And if
dark matter is annihilating at the center
of the galaxy, one of the things it
should be doing is spewing out neutrinos.
And so these neutrino telescopes are
looking for this signal and, uh, the way you
would do it, because these
neutrinos attract so faintly or feebly with
matter, what you need to do is
essentially watch a very gigantic volume of
some detection material. So then
you have a statistical chance of sort of catching
one of these neutrinos. Uh,
so if a neutrino were to hit water or ice,
it emits a blue light, something
called a Cerenkov light, and the idea is if
you can watch for this light, then
you can reinstruct the energy of the neutrino,
where it came from, and things
like that. Where do you find such a big volume
of water? Well, lake Baikal in
Siberia is one such place. It's a lake that's
800-kilometers long, about 40,
50-kilometers wide, if not wider, it's more
than a mile deep, and it's
absolutely clear water. It's one of the most
pristine lakes that you will find
in the world. And, uh, so that's where I went
to see -- umm, that's the, uh,
view of lake Baikal from the coast of the,
uh, from the coast where the
experiment, uh, offices were situated. Offices
is a very loose term. I'll show
you why. Umm, and you'll notice that this
is a frozen lake, umm, and when I
called up the scientists saying, can I come
and visit you? They said, of course
you can but you have to come in winter. Uh,
and, uh, this was Siberia in peak
winter. And the reason why they do this is
that the detectors are essentially
things called photo-multiplier tubes. Now,
photo-multiplier tubes are -- you
can think of them as the opposite of television
tubes. So in television tube
you supply electricity and you get out photons.
In a photo-multiplier tube,
if -- if it detects photons, it gives you
an electrical signal. That's all --
in very basic terms that's what they are.
So they've got these giant spheres of
photo-multiplier tubes that have been submerged
about one kilometer deep into
the lake and they're essentially watching
for a neutrino coming to hit a
molecule of water and trying to look for that
blue light. There are about 228
of these, uh, uh, photo-multiplier tubes deep
inside the lake. If you are
working, uh, in summer, or autumn, or something
like that, when the lake is not
frozen, you would need ships and you would
need submersibles to go down and wire
these things. The Russians, unfortunately,
have been working on a very tight
budget, especially after the fall of the Soviet
Union the moneys that have come
into them are very little. So they work in
winter. They wait for the lake to
completely freeze over and then they use the
lake's surface as a platform. They
set up their ice camp on top of the ice, they
cut holes in the ice, they know
where their detectors are under the water
-- they cut holes in the ice and then
essentially get their cranes and wrenches
and get the instruments out. They
have two months to do their work. Any repairing,
any maintenance has to be done
and then they have to get out before the ice
melts. So it's a pretty amazing
operation. This particular picture, the -- the
line of black darts that you're
seeing is the ice camp and we're about 4-kilometers
from -- from the ice camp on
the near shore. The -- the far shore is 40-kilometers
away and you can -- you
can imagine the size of those mountains. That's
40-kilometers away. This is a
picture of, uh, the Russians and some German
physicists working on the ice. And
I still can't believe that one guy. Uh, I
remember being shocked by him. Umm, he
was working bear-chested all day long can
those are sub -- you're standing on
ice, one-meter thick ice, uh, and you can
see the buoys that have been pulled
out. These buoys are the ones that are the
very top of the detector. So every
winter they go there, cut a hole in the ice,
a diver dives in, into fridged
waters and essentially locates the buoy and
gets it out and using that they haul
out the so-called string of photo-multiplier
tubes. These -- they're just long
strings which are all the way sort of 1 kilometer
underwater. And, uh, this is
a picture of what the photo-multiplier tubes
look like. So, uh, pairs of these
are essentially strung down into the water.
And, uh, just a scene of how the
lake looks there. This is the old Trans-Siberian
railway which goes along that
section of the lake. It's not used by the
Trans-Siberian railway anymore. Uh,
local trains trundle past once a day and they
are the ones that bring in
supplies. Uh, and the old railway buildings
are the ones being used by the
scientists for their living quarters. So when
I said "offices" that's what I
meant. This is one of their office buildings.
It's probably a hundred-year-old
railway building that's been converted into
their control room. Umm, very, very
basic, uh, umm, living conditions because
they're working on extremely little
money. You can imagine $20 million spent over
20 years. Uh, this kind of
science experiment if it's being done in Europe
or America -- and there are
experiments like this being done -- they will
have already spent about
300 million in a few years and these guys
have spent 20 million in 20
years. And they are a pioneering telescope.
They were the first to detect
certain kinds of neutrinos using a natural
body of water. Umm, this is our
drinking water. Every morning we would go
to the lake shore, dig a hole in the
ice, get the Lake Baikal water into a bucket
and so you can imagine it was a
lovely experience, a fairly rough experience,
uh, but then that's what they do
every year. Uh, I was quite, uh, in awe of
their abilities in terms of enduring
this cold. Umm, so on the very last day, uh,
I was, uh, told by my German
physicist host that since I'd come there for
an adventure I should go sleep on
the lake at night, until then I was sleeping
on the shore and, uh, I thought,
well, that sounds very good. Uh, and then
he mentioned that be prepared at
the -- in the middle of the night to literally
jump out of his sleeping bag and
if you're in your underwear to just run out
on the ice in your underwear. I was
really shocked. I didn't know what he meant.
He said that the ice actually
moves. It heaves, uh, and at daytime you don't
notice it because you're working
but if you're sleeping and then you start
thinking about it. There's a mile of
water underneath and this is a massive lake.
It's not a lake, it's a sea and
there are waves and -- and the ice is constantly
heaving and it's very, very
frightening apparently and as if that wasn't
enough he also told me, well, and
there are earthquakes out here.
>> [Laughing]
Anil: And, uh, so by then I was not ready
to go. I -- I really was getting
frightened and I didn't want to go and sleep
on the ice. But a lot of things
had been set in motion by then and some -- some
person had given up his bed and
he'd gone to sleep where else. So I made it
there and there was a graduate
student in one of those cabins who was sharing
the cabin with me and he welcomes
me by saying, oh, don't worry. There are earthquakes
here all the time. As if
that was meant to reassure me that nothing
happens and, uh, didn't. And so I
laid out on the bed and the first thing that
caught my attention was the sounds.
There were these gunshot-like sounds, whips
cracking or doors getting shut and it
was the ice cracking. So it was -- the ice
is constantly moving and cracking
underneath you. There's a mile of water underneath
and by then I was absolutely
frightened. So I asked him, so, you know,
how do you -- how do you manage to
sleep? He said, oh, as long as there are sounds
you don't have to worry. All
that means is the ice is just protesting.
It's when the sounds are -- have
gone, that means the cracks have opened up
long -- large enough that there is no
sound anymore, that's when you need to get
out of here. So suddenly, uh --
>> [Laughing]
Anil: So suddenly the sounds were like a lullaby.
I actually slept very
peacefully. So anyway, this was an amazing
experiment.
Uh, from there on to see
the Very Large Telescope in Chile, the "Very
Large Telescope". Very, very
interesting named one. Astronomers, uh, when
it comes to naming telescopes
seems -- seem to have great imaginations.
Umm, the next one -- the next one in the
line is called the "Extremely Large Telescope".
>> [Laughing]
Anil: And apparently there's one more in the
works which is going to be called
the "Overwhelmingly Large Telescope" so, uh
--
>> [Laughing]
Anil: But reason I went to Chile is because,
uh, the Atacama -- this is flying
into Santiago, the Andes in the background,
from there to a town called
Antofagasta and then two-hour drive to, uh,
into the Atacama Desert, a pretty
high place called Mount Paranal, which is
at 9,000 feet. So this is just the
road trip and that's how the landscape looks.
It's just absolutely dry. Uh,
the Atacama Desert is pretty much the driest
place on earth. They have in some
of these regions, especially near where the
telescope is, it hasn't rained for
decades. There's not a blade of grass, no
sign of life, uh, NASA uses this
region to -- to do their tests on their Mars
rovers and that's where they're
building telescopes and you -- you might wonder
why. Well, partly because it's
dry. Water vapor is a terrible thing for telescopes
because, uh, water vapor
in the atmosphere absorbs light and so you
can imagine light coming to us from
a galaxy, say, a billion light years away.
So it's traveled billions of years,
and then in the last segment of its trip about
a few kilometers of the
atmosphere can ruin that light. So the water
vapor can absorb it or the
turbulent layers of the atmosphere can smudge
the light. So essentially what
astronomers constantly try to do is get to
very, very dry regions and also to
get high about the lower layers of the atmosphere
which is why you find them --
find them on mountain tops. There are other
climactic regions that are useful.
On the -- on the -- on the shore of Chile,
the coast of Chile which is not very
far from this place, there's a low -- there's
a cold current called the Humboldt
Current that flows north along the coast and
that current pulls down the clouds.
Uh, so there's an inversion layer of clouds
that's created. So when you're
standing up on the mountain top you don't
see clouds on the top, you see clouds
down below you. And so essentially leaves
the mountain top with about 300 days
of clear skies. Absolutely cloudless skies.
So imagine you're flying an
airplane at 40,000 feet and you look down
and you see clouds. Well, that's what
you see here except the clouds are down at
6,000 feet and the summit of the
mountain is above that. In that dry region
the astronomers have sort of built a
residence where they stay. It's a subterranean.
Part of it is underground and
when you step inside this is what you see.
It's one of the most amazing little,
uh, places. It's very, very humid. They've
managed to sort of put a swimming
pool in there to keep it humid, uh, because
if you're going to be working there
for weeks, months on end you need the humidity
so this is the place where they
stay and right outside is -- that's the mountain
on which the telescopes have
been built. You can barely see the domes at
the top and these are the four, uh,
telescopes, uh, call -- that make up the Very
Large Telescope. So each
telescope is 8.2-meter primary mirror and
at the time that they were built --
and even now -- they're -- they're among the
largest, uh, telescopes in
existence and especially four in such close
proximity. There's nowhere else on
earth you'll find these such telescopes. Umm,
you -- you might recall the, umm,
uh, earthquake in Chile recently and you will
wonder why they would build such
fancy equipment in, uh, in places like Chile.
Well, obviously the skies are
wonderful which is why they want to build
them but at the same time you have to
deal with earthquakes. And this mirror -- this
is one of the mirrors of the
VLT -- you can see that shiny bit, that's
8.2 meters across and it's 18
centimeters thick and the whole thing weighs,
just the mirror, weighs about 23 tons.
And it's so heavy and, uh, relatively thin
compared to its diameter that as the
telescope is moving, uh, sort of from zenith
to our horizon and back and forth
the mirror is going to warp a bit because
the gravitational force is moving on a
change as it, uh, it changes orientation.
And that's enough to change the shape
of the mirror enough to mess up your observations.
So actually underneath the
mirror there are about a 150 pistons that
are constantly pulling and pushing at
the mirror to keep it in shape. So essentially
the mirror is not anchored.
It -- it's floating on these pistons so if
an earthquake were going to happen it
would just rattle around and break, you know?
There's no -- nothing holding it.
But the amazing thing is that you can't see
it very clearly in this picture but
there are clamps all the way around the periphery
of the mirror and the moment
they sense a tremor, these clamps hold on
to the mirror, 23 tons of it, and just
lift it right off the supports and just anchor
it to the superstructure. And
then the superstructure is designed to just
sway with the earthquake. So the
idea then is that the mirror is not going
to rattle around and it's just going
to, you know, if the earthquake is not severe
-- if it's severe enough to damage
the superstructure that's another thing but
for most earthquakes this will work
and it has worked in the past. Umm, let me
just, uh -- so the reason I went to
see the VLT was to understand. I mentioned
dark matter. We don't understand what,
about 90 percent of the matter in the universe
is made of, but about a
decade ago astronomers were looking at, uh,
what I call the supernovae, type one
supernovae which are just stars that are dying
and they were using these stars
to figure out how the expansion of the universe
has changed over time. You
know, Hubble found out that the universe is
expanding, uh, since the Big Bang
and then the -- the expectation among, uh,
physicists was that this expansion
should now be slowing down because the gravity
of the matter in the universe
should be, uh, starting to pull back the universe
in a sense. So if you were to
observe how the expanse -- expansion rate
is progressing in the recent past, say
the last few billion years, the idea was that
this expansion rate should be
slowing down and they found exactly the opposite,
that in the last, uh, few
billion years the expansion of the universe
instead of slowing down is actually
speeding up. Something is blowing apart the
universe and that something turns
out is the energy of space time itself, that
the vacuum of space, meaning
everything. This, where we are standing, this
is also vacuum of space. You
know, in between galaxies. Essentially all
of the universe is contained in this
vacuum of space and that fabric of space time
has some energy and when they
total up how much energy that is, it turns
out to be about 3-quarters of the
matter and energy in the universe. So this
pie chart -- now I can show this
happily to a technology crowd without getting
gasps. But, uh, that's our view
of the universe now. We have dark energy which
is 73 percent, we have dark
matter which is about 23 percent, and normal
matter 4 percent. So all our
theories so far in physics, theories that
have been verified and confirmed in
experiments can only be vouched for 4 percent
of the matter. The rest of the
universe, 96 percent of the universe, is a
mystery. Mystery of source. We have
theories but really we have no experimental
evidence to tell us what dark matter
is, we don't really understand dark energy.
There are many outstanding
questions about where this, uh, energy of
the fabric of space time comes from,
has it changed over time, you know, how will
it effect the universe in the
future, things like that and we really don't
know. So the whole point of this
book was to basically visit various experiments
that are going to start answering these
questions. And so the big questions, what
is dark matter, what is dark
energy? Uh, I've just spoken about that. The
other two big things is, uh,
reconciling quantum mechanics with Einstein's
General Relativity. And quantum
mechanics we know works really well. It's
been verified endlessly by
experiments but it works at things at the
microscopic level and Einstein's
General theory of relativity same thing. It's
been verified really well but
it's a theory of gravity on cosmological scales,
so for large distances. There
are situations in physics where these two
things have to be combined. Take the
Big Bang. Uh, the Big Bang the universe was
supposed to be smaller than a
proton if you can imagine that and -- but
at the same time all of the energy of
the universe was compressed in a tiny volume
so it had extremes of gravity. So
you need Einstein's relativity to deal with
gravity but you need quantum
mechanics to deal with the microscopic volumes
and, uh, when you put these two
together, they don't work. So you have two
pillars of modern physics,
relativity and quantum mechanics, that work
beautifully on their own but
whenever you need to bring them together they
don't. And so there is this
question to find this theory of what's called
quantum gravity so I talk about
that in the book. And then there's the physics
beyond the standard model. I --
I talked about how 4 percent of the universe
can be explained. Well, most of
that can be explained by this thing called
the standard model of particle
physics which is essentially a theory of all
of the particles of matter,
electrons, protons, neutrons, all of that,
and the forces that act upon them,
all except gravity and it's a very well-tested,
uh, theory, the standard model
of particle physics and we know there has
to be things beyond that because
standard model cannot explain dark matter
for instance, it doesn't have much to
say about dark energy, it cannot reconcile
quantum mechanics with relativity.
So we know that there is physics beyond it.
So again the experiments are
beginning to provide us clues about that.
>> [Pause]
Jesse: So we can go onto yet another chapter
or we can leave that for those who
still need to buy the book or those who have
already got it. I was wondering if
you wanted to open it up for Q and A for a
little bit. We have about ten to 15
minutes left.
Dr. Carlson: I'll quickly run through probably,
uh, Antarctica a little bit.
Jesse: Sure.
Anil: So people -- just a quick run through.
Jesse: Sounds good.
Anil: So one of the most extreme places I
went to was Antarctica. This
is flying from New Zealand to, umm, to McMurdo
station in Antarctica, the U.S.
base. This is the first sighting of the Antarctic
-- the southern ocean of
Antarctica and the ice flows. This is landing
in Antarctica. Uh, that's the
plane. Uh, we landed on the Ross Ice Shelf.
You can imagine that plane. It's
a B-17. It lands on the ice shelf, this is
the Ross Ice Shelf which is about
200 feet thick. It's about the size of France
and, uh, that is summer.
>> [Pause]
Anil: And, uh, we're -- we were taken on a
bus to the station and the bus was
called Ivan the Terebus. Very nice bus. And,
uh, you -- this is just a view
from the American, uh, base. Those are the
Trans-Antarctic mountains in the
back and in the foreground you can see a hut.
I don't know if it's clear to you
but there is a small hut here. That's a hut
that was built in 1902 by Robert
Scott in his men when they first landed in
Antarctica and you can go into the
hut and you can still see things like that
last meal that was being cooked
and -- and the clothes that they wear that
have been left behind, the biscuit
tins they brought with them from England on
their ship. Umm, it's so cold that
nothing has gone bad. Even the seal meat that
they used -- the seal that they
killed is lying outside you could probably
still eat it. Umm, this is a view of
the American base from a hill just next to
it called Observation Hill and it --
it actually resembles a little mining town.
It's often been said that it
reminds people of -- I haven't been to Montana
or Wyoming but apparently there
are mining towns that look like that. Uh,
just more views. There's a volcano
right next to McMurdo called Mount Erebus.
This is the highest volcano --
active volcano in the southern hemisphere,
umm, or it's the southern most active
volcano. It's 13,000 feet high and it's active.
It's spewing out, you know,
gas and smoke and all that but there are glaciers
on the top. So you can
imagine what kinds of extremes of, uh, nature
exist in Antarctica. Umm, at the
very top of that hill from where I took these
pictures is a cross to
commemorate -- I mean, this is in memory of
Robert Scott and his men. In 1911
and 12 they actually made it to the South
Pole but on their way back they --
they basically couldn't make it back to McMurdo
and they died about -- in their
tents about a 150 miles away so this cross
is in memory of that. I was there to
watch the launch of, uh, an experiment into
the stratosphere. Umm, this is a --
an experiment that is trying to look for antimatter.
One of the big questions
in cosmology and physics is, where did all
the antimatter go? The universe,
when it began matter and antimatter should
have been produced in equal
quantities and ideally they should have just
annihilated each other and all we
should have been left with is energy except
we have a universe made of
ostensibly matter. So some -- there are theories
that there might be galaxies
of antimatter out there and this experiment
was looking for one. And, uh, it is
launched using something called a long-duration
balloon. This is the balloon
fabric being laid out on the ice shelf, uh,
and at the very far end, uh, you'll
see two trucks. They -- they have 12 cylinders
each of very, very highly
compressed helium. Umm, and the balloon is
being filled up with helium. It
takes about an hour to fill it up and the
helium, in the cold of Antarctica, is
compressed. It doesn't expand to its true
volume. When the balloon actually
reaches the upper stratosphere, about 40-kilometers
altitude, it, uh, it -- the
helium expands to 1 million cubic meters.
1 million cubic meters. You can
imagine the size of that. The balloon is 400
feet across. It looks like half
the size of a full moon when you look from
the ground if you can see it on a
clear day, and you can. Umm, so this is the
balloon just getting filled. It's
an awesome sight and, uh, and that's pretty
much how the setup looks. And when
the helium has been filled they release the
balloon and it just takes off.
Takes about five hours to get to the upper
stratosphere and in the upper
stratosphere it just goes around and around
the South Pole for two weeks, the
experiment does its thing, and then they detonate
an explosive, radio controlled
explosive, the balloon fabric flies away,
and the -- the payload parachutes down
on to the ice and recovering that is another
story. We won't go into that but,
uh, they have to do all sorts of things to
recover that. And then from there I
went to the South Pole but maybe we are out
of time now. So happy to take
questions here.
Jesse: First, let's give Anil a round of applause.
>> [Applause]
Jesse: So we'll go into a brief Q and A. Unfortunately
we have to be out of
that room in about eight minutes or so --
Anil: Sure.
Jesse: But if I -- if people would like autographs
or questions afterwards I'm
sure he'll be willing to stick around. So
if you have questions, please come up
to the mic. I'll start off. You spoke briefly
about how it's a fairly
different type of physics book if for no other
reason because it's typically
someone involved in the experiment writing
about it and it's usually about a
successful experiment and this is about experiments
that aren't failures but
they're certainly not, uh, solid successes
just yet per se. Umm, and you also
talked about physicists having -- almost being
as passionate about setting up
and executing the experiment as they are about
-- about eventually finding
success in order to keep themselves going.
Anil: Yep.
Jesse: So, you know, do you have any thoughts
about why you approached it in
this way and did the scientists have any thoughts
about how you were approaching
it as well?
Anil: Well, the scientists I met were experimentalists
mostly. I mean, I did
meet theorists but they form a small section
of the book. So the
experimentalists were actually very, very
happy because they don't get exposure
normally. So all the physics books tend to
be about the theorists and the big
theories. So they were actually very pleased
to be showing me around and
showing me these experiments. The reason why
I wanted to do it this way was just
because I -- I have a very soft spot for physics
and cosmology in a sense I
think it is one of the loveliest, uh, sciences
out there and has a profound
effect on me and I wanted to communicate that
to people, uh, who normally would
be, uh, put off by, you know, words like "particle
physics," or "theories", you
know, and stuff like that. And this was a
way in which to reach out to a far
greater number of people by actually talking
of the places and the people who do
these experiments. Umm, so that's in terms
of one angle for the book is just to
broaden the scope of how you tell the stories
in physics. Uh, the other thing
also was to make a point that physics is actually
in some sort of a crisis. As
we saw, 96 percent of the universe we haven't
a clue. And the only way these
theories are gonna get verified are from experimental
data and we have a very,
very big shortage of good experimental data
at this point and so this was a way
of saying that this is the next generation
of experiments that are going to
hopefully lead us towards new physics.
>> [Pause]Well, I've got a few questions.
Please come to the mic, though, so we
can hear.
>> [Pause]
>> Relatively simple question. How did these
get funded?
Anil: Depends. Uh, different agencies like
the South Pole stuff gets funded by
the NSF mostly. Uh, in fact most of the science
in the South Pole is funded by
the NSF. The balloon experiments, NASA has
a big say in it, uh, so the balloons
are actually launched by NASA and the individual
researchers have to make
proposals so that NASA can then carry their
experiments up. Umm, the dark
matter experiments, I'm sure there is federal
funding, state funding, all sorts
because the experiment that I went to see
is actually being done by physicists
mostly based in Berkeley and Stanford. So
I'm sure Berkeley and Stanford have a
say in the funding and NSF must have some.
>> Thank you.
>> [Pause]
>> Umm, thanks for -- for the talk and especially
for the pictures. I think
that really makes some of these experiments
come alive and I was just thinking
it would be a great candidate for, like, a
-- either a documentary or a
collection of photos to go along with the
book. Have you looked into that?
Anil: Yeah. So I've put some pictures. I was
asked that very thing many times
so I ended up putting, uh, pictures on a web
site. So just edgeofphysics.com.
So the pictures are there. Documentaries.
Yeah, a couple of television people
have approached but television apparently
is a very different business. So they
say something and nothing happens for many
years so I'm not -- I'm not holding
my breath on that. I don't know. Umm.
>> [Pause]
>> Umm, in dealing mostly with experimental
physicists in the course of writing
this book, umm, did you get a good sense or
any sense in general of sort of
where they tended to stand with respect to
some of the grand unification Theory
of Everything, String Theory, prospects for
unified physics? Or did they tend
to just sort of compartmentalize themselves
to their own spheres of study?
Anil: They -- they tend to do both. Depending
on who you talk to on a given
experiment, some people are very compartmentalized,
they are very focused on the
experiment that they're doing. Umm, the problem
with String Theory and the
Theory of Everything at this point is that
they are very far from making
predictions that can be experimentally tested.
So I actually just focused on
two things, uh, in the book, uh, that may
help support String Theory. One is
the possible precise measurement of the curvature
of space time. There are
certain models in String Theory cosmology
that predict that the curvature of
space time should be just a slight bit negative
as opposed to -- we think the
universe is flat right now but there are -- there's
enough errors in the
measurement that it allows for a negative
curvature. So that's one. It's not
proof of String Theory. It's just one of the
possible things that String Theory
cosmology predicts. Umm, it's still disputed.
Even that is disputed. The
other big thing that actually would be a boost
for String Theory -- again, not
a -- not a proof but a boost -- is the detection
of something called
supersymmetry. Umm, I talked about physics
beyond the standard model and, uh,
one of the physics that's, uh, beyond the
standard model is called supersymmetry
which just says that every particle that we
know of, electrons, quarks, gluons,
everything, photons, all of them have a partner
particle, a much heavier partner
particle that existed early in the universe
and has sense decayed and gone away.
We might be able to create that at the large
Hedron collider. Now, if they
create supersymmetric particle and supersymmetric
theories start getting
verified, that would be a huge thing for String
Theory because most String
Theory models require the universe to be supersymmetric.
Again, it wouldn't constitute
proof because the universe can be supersymmetric
but not stringy. So yeah.
Jesse: All right. Well, and that wraps up
the time we have. If there are any
other questions, if you'd like to chat about
his book briefly it'll be out in
the lobby for a few more minutes but again
thank you, Anil.
Anil: My pleasure.
>> [Applause]